I have a really interesting video to
look at with you today we are truly
seeing the worst of what a dishonest and
incompetent administration is capable of
dr. Seema Verma was interviewed by Fox
News's Martha McCallum now dr. Verma is
the administrator of the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services in the
trump administration and part of the
coronavirus task force she went on Fox
News and was asked six times by martha
maccallum very specific questions about
the number of tests i see use and
ventilators available for coronavirus
okay Trump has been insisting for weeks
anyone who wants a test can get it can
get a test they can't that's not true
Trump has been saying people who are
flying into the country are being tested
no they're not they're sometimes just
having their temperature taken Trump
says there are more than enough tests
there are not Trump pretends like our
cases numbers are accurate because we're
testing so many people were not the
numbers aren't accurate we might have
half a million people currently infected
and I have to say this is not praise of
anything other than martha maccallum in
these five minutes
okay it's not praise of Martha in
general it's not praise of Fox News it's
merely martha maccallum realized she was
being snowed she does a good job of
exposing this Trump robot who can't stop
lying and can't answer a single question
so I'm gonna play for you a bunch of
questions which essentially ask the same
thing what is the number of actual tests
available what about the icy use what
about the ventilators and you will
notice how every single time dr. Seema
Verma just talks about something
different and martha maccallum tries to
bring her back and dr. Verma just again
answers about something else when even
Fox News hosts have to expose a trump
bot for obvious lies and deception you
know they're being more deceptive and
dishonest than usual let's get right
into it
my pleasure how are we doing on these
tests I remember last week I believe
Alex a czar the HHS secretary said that
there would be millions of them out
there by the end of the week how's that
happened you know our focus is on making
sure that people that need tests can get
tests and so one of the things that's
already available is that at every
Public Health Laboratory across the
nation these tests are available what
we're working on now is to increase the
capacity in the private healthcare
system because most of us when we go get
tests we don't go to a public health lab
you're used to going to your doctor's
office they order the tests and that
usually is handled through our private
healthcare system and so we've been
working with the private system to
essentially ramp up so we can make sure
that those tests are available our focus
is on making sure people who need the
test get it so we're working on capacity
at private versus public it's not an
answer so Martha McCallum tries again
you promised millions of tests by now
and we don't have the right doc so is it
true that there are millions of those is
it's now almost the end of the week so
has that mark been met that we heard
about from secretary is there because I
was at a doctor for something else the
other morning and asked and they said
you know we can't get him we've been
calling we called the state we called
here we can't we can't get our hands on
them and then I heard it from another
doctor earlier today with the same story
with a patient that she wanted to test
and she tried to get a test for that
patient and was unable to do so well
today one of the things that we did dr.
Hahn and I hosted a call with over 1,600
representatives from hospitals to work
with them around how they can do the
testing inside their hospital
laboratories the other thing that we're
focused on is for pairing the entire
healthcare system some of the
conversations that we've been having
with hospitals is making sure that they
have again no answer question is you
promised millions of tests my doctor
says they have none she answers we'll
listen we've been having phone calls
with hospital reps about testing and
hospitals we've issued guidance no tests
no answer and martha maccallum is
starting to get irritated she
filibustered there for more than a
minute eventually again martha maccallum
manages to get a word in and asks
another time and this time she says well
we have ICU shortages we have ventilator
shortages we have shortages of equipment
to do tests okay but in terms of actual
equipment we heard Bernie Sanders today
for one coming out and saying that
there's a major shortage of ICU units
we've heard that there's a shortage of
ventilators even swabs and equipment for
the actual tests what's being done about
that and how concerned are you that when
when we these numbers do start to rise
which doctor fowey has told us to expect
that there'll be enough ICU units enough
ventilators to help the people who do
get sick in this country well that's why
we have an emergency prepared system you
know we were used to dealing with
disasters if we look at some of the
disasters that have happened around
hurricanes in Puerto Rico in Florida
there is a system in place to make sure
that folks that are on the front lines
have the equipment and the supplies that
they need are you saying that we do have
we're doing at CMS is to have a rapid
dialogue with health care providers so
we're meeting with providers well we
have a system but the question was about
equipment oh but there's no answer to
that we have a system we have meetings
we have guidance they have plenty of
dialogue and guidance clearly but what
about the equipment more filibustering
about tests and equipment Martha comes
back in again and this time dr. Seema
won't even let her ask again just
talking over martha maccallum the needs
that they have yeah I know there being
enough sure that people understand hey
before you go into your doctor's office
you can call your doctor on the phone
and have a discussion with them and they
can tell you whether you need to come in
or not and that's really important
because we don't want to have people
hunters travel unnecessarily if they're
not feeling well no and if they if they
come into a healthcare facility they
could also be putting others at risk
Martha tried to ask again and the doctor
just said you know call your doctor have
a discussion
eventually martha maccallum gets to ask
one more time and this one is just nuts
dr. Verma goes directly into saying
Trump has been bold and decisive and
check out the look on martha maccallum
face she can't believe it it's a smirk
of disgust as the last big lie is told
and dr. Verma knew it was a five-minute
interview and this was the last 30
seconds praise Trump and avoid answering
the question I'm sure that that
providers can use
tell telehealth and telemedicine right
to serve their patient at that point
here quite quite a bit and I think it's
a very important point to make but
before you let you go I want to ask you
one more time are there gonna be people
in this country who don't get a
ventilator if they need one are you
concerned that the actual physical
equipment that is needed to serve the
people who will get sick is out there
can you reassure everyone tonight that
there is not a shortage of ventilators
or ICU units and that's why the
president has taken such a bold and
decisive action right we're not waiting
for this to get worse we're not waiting
for this to be a crisis in our health
care systems and that's why the
mitigation strategies that he announced
last night limiting travel from Europe
not allowing that you know we've given
travel advisories on cruise ships that's
why we're taking all in this action
because we don't want to put stress on
the healthcare system okay that's not a
direct answer to the question but it
sounds like a hope that there won't be
enough sick people and we won't run that
one right out ventilators because we
have mitigated and we certainly hope
that we certainly hope that's the case
guys this was five minutes martha
maccallum asked five times tried to ask
six times was only able to ask five
times about tests and ventilators and I
see use and there was not a single
factual answer from this Trump bot who
just it's almost like her software
malfunction then she just kept repeating
the answers to a different she was
working off of a script for a different
interview it didn't matter she loaded up
that script and read it for this
interview and it's dishonest it's
disgusting and you know this is nothing
other than saying at least here martha
maccallum kept asking and said those
aren't really answers to my questions
what else can we do they're just not
going to be straight with us